hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
i'm going to be going over barbiturates
and as always whenever you get done
watching this youtube video you can
access the free quiz that will test you
on this content
so let's get started barbiturates are a
class or group of sedative hypnotic
drugs that actually depress
our central nervous system now how they
do this is that they amplify the effects
of a specific neurotransmitter
called gaba and gaba stands for gamma
aminobacteria
acid and this is actually an inhibitory
neurotransmitter
now we'll talk more about this whenever
we talk about the mechanism of action
of these drugs but i want you to keep
that concept in the back of your mind
now over the years barbiturates have
really been slowly replaced
with benzodiazepines especially for the
treatment of insomnia
and anxiety now why is this well
barbiturates
have a very low therapeutic index
and this means that there is a small
threshold between the therapeutic dose
versus the toxic dose
so there is a higher incidence of
overdose with the barbiturates compared
to
benzodiazepines now benzodiazepines and
barbiturates
they target the same receptors in the
body
but they do it differently and how they
cause
this ion channel to open up and
hyperpolarize the cell
so we decrease firing potential and
with benzos there's actually an antidote
to reverse the effects
of an overdose if it does occur with
barbiturates there is not one
now how can you recognize these drugs as
a nurse so you're looking at a patient's
medication list
how do you know that this patient is
taking a barbiturate
well something that can help tip you off
is whenever you look at that generic
name look at the end of that name
and at the end most of them will end in
barbitol
or i-t-a-l with an exception
of pronadone which is used to treat
seizures it does not follow that rule
but some barbiturates that actually
follow that rule include
like phenobarbital and this is used to
treat seizures in some patients
especially
young children or it can be used where a
patient has
increased intracranial pressure next we
have penta barbitol
and this tends to be used in veterinary
medicine or
in capital punishment cases now you may
have heard
of thiopental which was used for this
but in 2011 it's no longer available for
use in the u.s
then we have psychobarbitol which tends
to be used prior to surgery
next is butabital which is actually used
to treat
migraines and it's like a combination
pill that contains like
acetaminophen and sometimes caffeine and
then lastly we have methyl hexatal
and this is typically used in anesthesia
now this leads us to what these
medications are used to treat
so barbiturates can be prescribed to
treat patients who have
seizures insomnia they can be used
before
surgery or to treat migraines and
sometimes for patients who have
increased intracranial pressure but how
do they
work and how do they actually depress
the central nervous system
and treat those conditions we'll help us
answer that
let's talk about the mechanism of action
of barbiturates
so at the beginning of the lecture i
said that these medications
amplify the effect of the
neurotransmitter gaba
and gaba remember is an inhibitory
neurotransmitter
so let's go back and let's review what
is a neurotransmitter
what does it do well a neurotransmitter
is a chemical agent that is produced by
a neuron
that transmits hence why we call it a
neurotransmitter
transmits messages to a specific
structure that it was designed to target
and many times
this target is another neuron so it can
send a message that is an inhibitory
message
or an excitatory message and we know
with gaba it's going to send
an inhibitory message whenever it's
released from that neuron
so to help us really visualize this
let's look at this illustration
here we have a neuron and as you can see
it is releasing a neurotransmitter which
is pictured in yellow
and this neurotransmitter is going to go
down and it's going to find its special
receptor that it binds with
and the receptor in this specific
animation is identified in
the red so once it binds and locks down
on that receptor
it's going to either sin an inhibitory
message
or an excitatory message depending on
what type of neurotransmitter we're
dealing with
so if it was sending an excitatory
message let's say it's an excitatory
neurotransmitter
this means that just as its name says
it's going to excite
it's going to increase the firing
potential
of that neuron so we're going to get a
response
however if it was an inhibitory
neurotransmitter just like what gaba is
it's going to inhibit impede that
message from being sent
so it's going to decrease firing
potential
so because of that we are going to get
a sedative hypnotic anxiolytic
effect and calm things down and depress
that central nervous system
now barbiturates are going to work to
affect
gaba receptors hence by amplifying the
effects
of this gaba neurotransmitter now
there's different types of gaba
receptors there are gaba a receptors and
gaba b
receptors for this lecture we're
specifically talking about
gaba a receptors so gaba receptors
many of them are found in the limbic
system
of the brain and this is the system that
helps us
process our emotions and really dictates
how we behave and respond to things
so these receptors are called
ligand-gated or ionotropic receptors
and these terms really are used to help
describe
how these specific receptors work to
complete their action
because when binding occurs at the
specific binding sites
you have this channel that's going to
open up and allow
i ion specifically chloride ions
to go down enter into the cell
hyperpolarize it
and this is going to decrease its firing
potential
so now let's take a more in-depth look
and let's talk about how these gaba-a
receptors
are affected once a barbiturate is in a
patient's system how does it actually
affect
that receptor to cause these effects so
the gaba a receptor is really cool in
how it's designed it has
five subunits it has two alpha subunits
two beta subunits and one gamma subunit
and in the middle is where our channel
is located you have a little pore there
and once binding occurs
that channel can become activated and do
its thing
so let's look here so we have in the
body we have our neurotransmitter gaba
being rained down and this patient has a
barbiturate in
their system so we have that hanging out
as well so
here is this gaba a receptor
and we have our neurotransmitter and
barbiturate
coming down and it's going to lock
itself on its special
site now the site where the
neurotransmitter gaba
is going to go is found between
the alpha and beta subunit you have two
of those those are the gaba
neurotransmitter binding site
and then here either on the alpha or the
beta subunit
will be where the barbiturate is going
to bind and lock down
so it's here with this little square
that i put on
the beta subunit so once this occurs
our gaba neurotransmitter has found its
binding site barbiturate has found its
binding site
we get results what's going to happen is
that this
channel is going to open and these ions
chlorides specifically is going to go in
through this channel and it's going to
go into the cell and it's going to
hyperpolarize the cell
now what this means is it's going to
make the cell negative because
chloride's negative
and it's going to decrease the firing
potential
so we're going to get these calming um
sedative hypnotic
effects because we're decrea we're
depressing
the central nervous system by how this
is working
now if you watch my lecture on benzos
that's really similar to how
benzodiazepines sort of work but they
had their little different binding sites
but the thing to remember about
barbiturates
is that it causes this chloride channel
to stay open longer so it increases the
duration
of how long this channel stays open so
we have more chloride flowing through
on the other hand benzos just cause that
channel to open more
often so that is the little subtle
difference between those two
now another interesting difference
between barbiturates and benzos that
benzos cannot do
is how high dosages of barbiturates can
influence these gaba a receptors
without the help of the neurotransmitter
gaba binding at its site
so whenever you have high dosages of
barbiturates
you can actually just get this channel
to open
up without the help of gaba which in a
sense
really makes them even more potent than
benzodiazepines now let's wrap up this
lecture and let's talk about nursing
responsibility
side effects and patient education and
to help us
remember those important concepts we
need to know let's remember the word
bar bits okay so first b
barbs and benzo differences so the
differences between barbiturates and
benzodiazepines because they're similar
in how
they affect this gaba-a receptor but
there are some differences we want to be
familiar with
so with these drugs barbiturates
and the benzos they have different
locations that they bind
on this gaba-a receptor like for
instance benzodiazepines
their binding site is found between the
alpha
and the gamma subunit with barbiturates
it tends to be found
either on the alpha subunit or the beta
subunit with barbiturates high doses can
influence the gaba a receptor
without the help of the gaba
neurotransmitter which is what we just
talked about benzos cannot do that
barbiturates have a very low therapeutic
index which makes the risk of overdose
more likely than with benzos there is no
antidote for barbiturates
and benzos are more commonly prescribed
for insomnia and anxiety
rather than the barbiturates due to that
high risk of
overdose plus the high risk of
dependency and addiction with the
barbiturate
and that leads us to a for abuse
addiction dependence is high risk with
barbiturates
so as a nurse you want to look at risk
factors that can increase your patients
risk
so are they using these long term that
can increase it
and what's their history do they have a
history of substance abuse in the past
or are they experiencing like any
suicidal ideation
because those factors can actually
increase these risk along with overdose
which leads us into r so recognize
overdose signs and symptoms you
definitely want to be able to recognize
if your patient is becoming toxic on
this
or they just present in the er with a
possible overdose you want to know
hey is this a cns depressant so
if an overdose does occur with a
barbiturate again there's no
antidote so they are supported depending
on how severe it is
supported with mechanical ventilation
because respiratory failure
is definitely a main thing that presents
they may need dialysis to help remove
some of those drug levels from the blood
or activated charcoal you want to
educate the patient who is taking a
barbiturate that they want to avoid
other medications that can increase the
risk of toxicity
like alcohol can and other cns
depressants like they wouldn't want to
take barbiturates and benzos together
so what are the signs and symptoms that
an overdose may be presenting
in your patient well to help you
remember those signs and symptoms
remember the mnemonic
lethal because this can definitely be
lethal
l is for loss of consciousness to the
point of a coma
e is for i pupils will be pinpoint and
then they'll progress
to dilation and become fixed as it
progresses
and the body shuts down t is for
tachycardia
and the heart rate will feel weak h is
for have
cold and sweaty skin a is for absent
reflexes
and then l is for low and shallow
respirations
next is b for be aware of patient safety
so whenever a patient takes a
barbiturate it's normal
side effects that they're going to feel
very relaxed
they're going to feel drowsy some can
feel euphoric
their senses are going to be extremely
dull and
they're not going to be able to think
clearly
so because of that because the drugs
doing what it's supposed to do
there can be a danger to themselves and
to others
so as the nurse you want to make sure
that the patient doesn't get up without
assistance because they are definitely
at risk for falls
you want to watch that bed position
because they can get up and fall and
hurt themselves so you want that
definitely in the lowest position
possible
with the side rails up also no important
decisions to be made at this time
whenever they're under the influence of
this
and if they are going to be at home they
don't need to be driving
or doing anything that requires
concentration because
they can hurt themselves or hurt others
and
let the patient be aware that there is a
risk of accidental overdose so they need
to take this drug
exactly as prescribed there's a risk of
addiction
and withdrawal signs and symptoms and
tolerance that can develop especially if
they're using these
long term then i for index is low
specifically that therapeutic index so
there's a fine line between that
therapeutic dose
and that toxic dose so as the nurse you
definitely want to monitor those serum
drug levels
and one drug level you definitely want
to be familiar with is
phenobarbital and it's anywhere between
15 to 40 micrograms per
milliliter so anything greater than that
that can mean our patient is toxic
and i have a whole video on lab values
that you want to know for nclex if you
want to access that video above to help
you study with that
next is t for tolerance can develop so
what is tolerance
well tolerance can develop when a
patient can no longer get the same
effects
from that drug so in order to get the
effects that they were getting before
they have to increase their dosage but
we've learned that with barbiturates
there's a fine line between that
therapeutic dose
and a toxic dose so this can lead
to accidental overdose and even death
and this tends to happen with patients
who are taking these long
term or who are abusing the drug and
then lastly we have
s for stopping the drug abruptly
can actually lead to withdrawal signs
and symptoms
and they can be anywhere from mild to
severe and this tends to happen with
patients who are using them
long term and it can happen as soon as
24 hours from when they last
had that dose of that drug so as a nurse
you definitely want to be familiar
with those signs and symptoms that a
patient is withdrawing from
a barbiturate because the patient's
going to need treatment to prevent shock
or eventually death so what are those
signs and symptoms well to help us
remember those signs and symptoms let's
remember the mnemonic
craves so c is for convulsions
r is for restlessness a is for agitation
v is for vomiting and nausea e
is for elevated temperature and then s
is
for sleep problems so again this can
actually be very severe and can progress
to shock and
eventually death okay now let's test
your knowledge on the material we just
covered by taking this quiz question
so this quiz question says barbiturates
influence the receptor's ion channel to
perform
one action a stay open longer
b open more often c shortening opening
time
or d open less often the answer is
a stays open longer because remember
barbiturates
increase the duration of how this ion
channel stays
open so more chloride ions will enter
into the cell and hyperpolarize it
benzodiazepines cause this channel to
open more often okay so if you would
like more free quiz questions to test
your knowledge on this material we just
covered you can access the link in the
youtube description below
and thank you so much for watching